>> Speaker 1: From the library
of Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Karen Jaffe: Hi.
Welcome. Have any of you been to
the Young Reader's Center before?
Well, we're glad to have you
and we hope you come back.
And today we have a very special
person whose name is Molly Idle.
And she is an author and
an illustrator of books
for young children your age.
And she has come all
the way from Arizona.
So I am going to turn the
program over to Molly and then,
at the end of the program,
the schools that have
ordered books can pick them
up at the reference desk.
There is a bag -- in one case, two
bags -- with your names on them.
Okay? Thank you.
>> Molly Idle: Thank you.
Miss Karen, could I get a
copy of each of the books
up here so that I can read them?
May I get a copy of
each of the books?
>> Karen Jaffe: Oh, sure.
The book is right there.
>> Molly Idle: So we can read.
Oh, perfect.
Good morning.
>> Children [Together]:
>> Molly Idle: How are
you guys doing today?
>> Children [Together]: Good.
>> Molly Idle: It is very
rainy outside today, isn't it?
[Children voice agreement]
I am really -- thank you.
Can I have The Flamingo, too?
Thank you.
I am really enjoying the rain.
Because, you know, I come from
Phoenix, Arizona, and it is a desert
and we don't often get
rain in the desert.
So to me, this is a real treat.
Water falling from the sky.
It's different for me.
Do you -- does it rain here often?
>> Children [Together]: Yes.
>> Molly Idle: Is it fun -- Oh, no!
Oh, that can be hard.
Unless -- it can be fun to
splash in the puddles, can't it?
>> Children [Together]: Yeah.
>> Molly Idle: Standing in the
water, making splooshing noises.
>> Child 1: No.
>> Molly Idle: Do you know,
some birds like the water, too.
I thought maybe we
could draw one together.
Hmm. I'm going to get
out some markers,
and let's see if you can
guess what I am going to draw.
Hmm. You know, when
I do my drawings,
I always start with simple shapes.
Now, you are all in
preschool and kindergarten,
so you have already learned
your shapes haven't you?
>> Children [Together]: Yeah.
>> Molly Idle: So you
know -- [Inaudible].
First grade?
Oh, my gosh!
You're so big.
So, circles and triangles
and rectangles.
I'm going to start
drawing with an oval.
How about this?
I'm going to put a small
oval right up here.
And then I'm going to
add another oval here.
Hmm.... Maybe.
Let's see.
What if I do two lines?
One here and here?
What do you think?
[Children Guessing Aloud]
A flamingo.
You guys are good guessers.
Shall we finish drawing him?
>> Children [Together]: Yeah.
>> Molly Idle: All right.
I'm going to add another oval
here, and maybe one here.
Have you guys learned about
three dimensional shapes?
Like spheres and pyramids
and cylinders?
>> Child: And like cubes.
>> Molly Idle: You got it -- cubes.
Cubes -- very good.
Well, I'm going to draw a cylinder.
>> Child: In circles?
>> Molly Idle: Circles
are good, too.
Let's see -- what if I
now add some triangles?
I could put one here to show
us where his beak would be,
and maybe here for a tail.
I could put one here.
Does anybody know what shape you
get when you put one triangle
on top of another triangle?
>> Children [Together]: Diamond.
>> Molly Idle: Very good!
You also get a fabulous
flamingo knee.
And then we could put
a triangle down here.
But that's just one leg.
And flamingos have two, don't they?
But they always stand on one.
>> [Child]: Are you going
to do a statue of it?
>> Molly Idle: Hmm --
kind of like a statue.
Have any of you ever done a
Connect the Dots puzzle before?
>> Children [Together]: Yes.
>> Molly Idle: Yes.
Well then you will
know what this is like.
This is like Connect the Dots, but
instead of connecting the dots,
I am going to connect the shapes
to help finish this flamingo.
And I just use all of our
simple shapes like a guide.
You know, flamingos stand on
one leg because they stand
in cold water trying to catch
their food and they have
to warm up their other leg.
Don't they?
Does anybody know what
flamingos eat?
>> Children [Together]: Fish.
>> Molly Idle: Fish?
They love shrimp.
And that is what makes them pink.
That is what makes flamingos pink.
So what if shrimp were blue?
Would flamingos be blue?
Exactly. Do you know?
I think flamingos have lovely --
look at that long straight leg.
Do you think maybe flamingos
would be good dancers?
>> Children [Together]: Yeah.
>> Molly Idle: I think so, too.
And in fact, I've got a story
about a flamingo who likes
to dance, who makes friends.
Yes! I thought we could
read that one today.
>> Child: I already read it.
>> Molly Idle: You have read it?
Well, maybe there is
somebody who hasn't.
>> Child: I haven't.
>> Children [Together]: I have.
>> Molly Idle: Well, let's see.
Did you know that there are some
stories you can read without words?
>> Child: Pictures?
>> Molly Idle: You can read the
pictures and you can read --
I bet you guys didn't already know
you could read another language.
You can read body language.
So, like, if your friend walks
into the classroom and looks
like this, how are they feeling?
>> Children [Together]: Happy.
>> Molly Idle: What if
their face looks like this?
>> Children [Together]: Sad.
>> Molly Idle: And they didn't
have to say a word, did they?
Hm-mm. You could read
their body language.
Hang on. So let's see if
we can read this book.
And I will try not to talk much.
Flora and the Flamingo.
Is he alone?
>> Children [Together]: Yes.
>> Molly Idle: Is he?
>> Children [Together]: No.
>> Molly Idle: Mmm.
Let's see who it is.
Flora. They look alike
-- kind of -- don't they?
>> Child: Yeah.
>> Molly Idle: Watch this.
Hmm. [Whistles].
Hmm. Hmm.
What do you think?
Does the flamingo want to play?
>> Children [Together]: Yes.
>> Molly Idle: Maybe.
Flora does.
Yep. Ooh -- tricky.
Mmm.
I bet you guys know
what this game is.
Hmm. Peek-a-boo.
Oh!
Oh, that is tricky, isn't it?
Ooh!
>> Child: Peek-a-boo.
>> Molly Idle: Uh-oh.
He's laughing.
Hmm.
Aww. How does Flora feel now?
>> Child: Sad.
>> And maybe he feels bad?
Maybe he'd help her up?
Hmm. I think she's not sure.
Do you think the flamingo
wants to make it up to her?
>> Children [Together]: Yeah.
>> Molly Idle: Aww.
And then, look at this, they
could help each other dance,
couldn't they?
Whoo-hoo. Hmm-hmm.
Hmm-hmm.
Plies are tricky for flamingos.
Their knees bend the wrong way.
Oooh! Very fancy.
[ Humming ]
Oh, look at this.
And a leap.
Oh.
Splash.
And a bow.
Do you think they ended up friends?
>> Children [Together]: Yes.
>> Molly Idle: Me, too.
I brought another story to
share with you today, too.
>> Child: You brought three.
>> Molly Idle: I did, but
I'm going to read two.
I think this book is
about making a friend.
But I brought a book today
that is about what happens
when three friends
get together to play.
Have you ever played with more
than one of your friends and it --
and it can be hard for
everyone to get along, right?
>> Children [Together]: Yeah.
>> Molly Idle: It can be
hard to decide what to play.
Mm-hmm. It's right there.
Flora and -- do you know
what kind of birds these are?
>> Children [Together]: Peacock.
>> Molly Idle: Yes.
Peacocks. Peacocks raise
their tail feathers
to get attention, don't they?
Tell me one thing.
>> Child: Not all -- do you know
only the boy are called peacocks?
>> Molly Idle: That is true.
And the girls are called
peahens, aren't they?
And they don't have
the fancy feathers.
>> Child: And the baby
is called peachicks.
>> Molly Idle: They would
be adorable -- like you!
All right.
So shall we read this
book and see what happens
when three friends get together
and have to cooperate to play?
Look who is here?
Flora! Hmm?
>> Child: Peacock.
>> Molly Idle: Just one?
Two. So how many friends are there?
>> Children [Together]: Three.
>> Molly Idle: Mm-hmm.
Does Flora want to play?
>> Children [Together]: Yes.
>> Child: No.
>> Molly Idle: Mm-hmm.
Do both the peacocks want to play?
>> Children [Together]: No.
>> Molly Idle: Mmm.
This guy?
>> Children [Together]: No.
>> Molly Idle: What about him?
>> Molly Idle: He's not sure, is he?
Not sure if he wants a new friend.
Well, these guys look happy.
But how does he look?
>> Child: Not happy.
>> Molly Idle: Not happy.
Look at this.
These guys are having
fun playing together.
One. Two.
Does he feel left out maybe?
>> Children [Together]: Yes.
>> Molly Idle: And he says, Humph!
Don't want to play.
Oh, dear. Hmmm.
Oh. Now they realize,
oh, we left him out.
Oh, dear.
I think Flora wants to
make him feel better.
Yes? But if she wants to play
with him, how does this one feel?
[Inaudible] Mm-hmm.
What will happen?
Now they are having fun.
But what about him?
>> Children [Together]: No.
>> Molly Idle: Hmm.
Sad. Like his feelings are
hurt a bit, maybe, huh?
And when you feel sad, sometimes
that makes you feel
something else, too.
Angry.
>> Child: Or jealous.
>> Molly Idle: Or jealous.
That's -- those are both true.
And sometimes when you are
angry you do not nice things.
Uh oh! Huh!
Uh oh! Oh, dear.
I don't have a good feeling about
how this is going to end, you guys.
Uh oh. They're pulling on her fan.
What's going to happen?
Uh oh. They ripped her fan.
Does anybody look happy now?
>> Children [Together] No.
>> Molly Idle: Mm-mm.
Does Flora still want to play?
>> Children [Together]: No.
>> Molly Idle: Mm-mm.
>> Child: They broke the fan.
>> Molly Idle: They broke the fan.
Do you think maybe they
could make it up to her?
>> Children [Together]: Yeah.
No.
>> Molly Idle: No?
I hope they can.
I like a happy ending.
Let's see.
Maybe if they work together.
>> Children [Together]: Whoa!
Oh! Wow! [Inaudible]
>> Molly Idle: There you go.
So, is everyone happy now?
>> Children [Together]: Yeah.
>> Molly Idle: Yeah.
>> Child: That was funny.
>> Molly Idle: Three friends now.
And that's the end.
There we go.
>> Child: Another one?
>> Molly Idle: Another one?
>> Child: Yeah.
>> Molly Idle: I do have one more.
Should we do a third?
>> Children [Together]: Yeah.
>> Molly Idle: Okay, one more!
What kind of bird is this?
>> Children [Together]: Penguin.
>> Molly Idle: Yes.
A penguin.
Do penguins live where
it is hot, hot, hot?
>> Children [Together]: No.
>> Molly Idle: No.
>> Children [Together]:
Where it's cold.
>> Molly Idle: Where it's cold.
And what happens to
water when it gets cold?
What does it turn into?
>> Children [Together]: Ice.
>> Molly Idle: Ice.
And do you know what
you can do on ice?
>> Children [Together]: Ice skate!
>> Molly Idle: Skate.
I think penguins would
be good ice skaters.
They might even be good friends.
This book is about what happens
when two friends have an argument.
Have you ever had an argument
with one of your friends?
>> Children [Together]: Yeah.
>> Molly Idle: And then,
4 if you're a good friend,
you have to figure out how
to say you're sorry
and make it up, right?
>> Children [Together]: Yeah.
>> Molly Idle: So let's
see what happens when Flora
and the penguin get together.
She's got her skates.
Who's coming?
>> Child: A penguin.
>> Molly Idle: Ooh!
Somebody else, too.
What's in the water swimming?
>> Child: Fish
>> Molly Idle: Fish.
I think she says, hey.
Huh -- more fish.
And more fish.
>> Child: And more fish.
>> Molly Idle: And now
they can skate together.
Back and forth and back and forth.
Oh, look at this.
They can get tricky.
Ah! And skate backwards.
Uh oh. But's what's behind them?
Look out. Ah!
Sploosh.
Does anybody know what
penguins like to eat?
>> Children [Together]: Fish.
>> Molly Idle: Fish.
Look out, fish.
Penguins love to fish.
But what about Flora?
>> Children [Together]: No.
>> Molly Idle: Hmm -- where
is he, she's wondering.
>> Child: Under water.
>> Molly Idle: Do you
think he'll catch the fish?
>> Children [Together]: No.
>> Molly Idle: Oh!
He got it.
He looks very pleased with himself.
Oh, look. He gave -- who
did he give the fish to?
>> Children [Together]: Flora.
>> Molly Idle: Does
she like the fish?
>> Children [Together]: No.
>> Molly Idle: Mmm.
But if you're a penguin,
wouldn't you like to get a fish?
>> Children [Together]: Yeah.
>> Molly Idle: Mm-hmm.
He thinks he gave her
a very nice present.
But what does she do with it?
>> Child: Toss it in the water.
>> Molly Idle: Look at his face!
How could you?
Oh, look. He's sticking
out his tongue at her.
And says --
He is mad, isn't he?
He says, Hump -- hmm-hmm-hmm.
Aww. Now she knows
she hurt his feelings.
She's taking off her skates.
>> Child: Uh oh.
>> Molly Idle: Do you
think they're done?
Do you think they're done playing?
>> Children [Together]: No.
>> Molly Idle: Is she going to go?
>> Children [Together]: Yes.
>> Molly Idle: Wait.
What is she doing with her laces?
She's fishing.
Do you think she could
catch a fish for him?
>> Children [Together]: Yes.
>> Molly Idle: Maybe.
There's one left.
I think they got a bite.
Let's see.
See if they can pull it out.
Ooh -- pull!
Oh no. Oh, no -- pull, pull, pull.
This is a tough fish.
One more time.
Pull. Oh! They got him.
Look out. Oh, yes!
They got him.
Happy penguin?
>> Children [Together]: Yes.
>> Molly Idle: Happy Flora.
>> Children [Together]: Yeah.
No.
>> Molly Idle: Yeah.
And now, where do you
think the fish is?
>> Child: In his mouth.
>> Molly Idle: Mm-hmm.
He ate the fish all up.
>> Child: It's in his tummy.
>> Molly Idle: In his tummy.
And off they go.
Do you guys know what
this symbol is?
>> Child: Figure eight.
>> Molly Idle: It's a figure eight.
It is also the infinity symbol.
Infinity means things go on forever
and I think they will
be friends forever.
The end. [Inaudible]
That's right.
Because good friends
are always there.
That's true.
Thank you guys for being
such good listeners today.
Can you please give yourselves
a big round of applause
for being such good listeners?
[ Applause ]
>> Child: Can we do one more?
>> Molly Idle: That's
all I brought for today.
But I'm glad you want one more.
That makes me happy.
It's so nice to visit
with you guys today.
Should we make one
more drawing, maybe?
>> Children [Together]: Yeah.
>> Molly Idle: One more drawing?
All right.
Let's see.
What if we draw a peacock?
>> Children [Together]: Yes!
>> Molly Idle: Yes?
>> Molly Idle: Let's draw a peacock.
>> Child: Why not a penguin?
>> Molly Idle: We could draw a
penguin, but I like peacocks, too.
Do you know, we could start
with simple shapes again?
We could. We could.
>> Child: I can see your shadow.
>> Molly Idle: You can?
We could make bunny ears.
Or a bird.
But -- oh, let's draw a bird
instead of making a shadow bird.
We'll draw a peacock.
I'm going to put another oval here.
And an up and down oval here.
>> Child: What are you doing?
>> Molly Idle: I am
going to make a peacock.
>> Child: And then
can we make a penguin?
>> Molly Idle: [Laughs] Let's see,
so we have an oval and an oval.
Let's put a triangle here.
>> Child: You'll see when it's done.
>> Molly Idle: That's right.
And an oval.
But you know what peacocks have.
[ Multiple conversations ]
[Laughs] I like that.
Let's divide things up.
Now, there's our simple shapes.
But now we can do connect
the shapes again, can't we?
And bring them all together.
Little peacock feet.
And they have little
top not feathers.
Oh, we almost forgot his wings.
Their wings have like a
checkerboard pattern on them, too.
Very fancy.
And they have on the
ends of their feathers.
Child: And they have circles.
>> Molly Idle: They do and those
circle feathers are called eye
feathers, because they look like --
>> Children [Together]: Eyes.
>> Molly Idle: Eyes.
Let's add some now.
>> Child: It scares away predators.
>> Molly Idle: It absolutely does.
You are a very knowledgeable
group about your birds.
Exactly. So it's like
we put all these ovals
and then we have to
put circles inside.
>> Child: Like a butterfly.
>> Molly Idle: Like a butterfly?
Butterflies use that, too.
You're absolutely right.
>> Child: And some fish!
>> Molly Idle: And some fish.
I don't know.
Oh, some fish have that
kind of camouflage.
You're right.
And there's a peacock.
Mm-hmm.
There we go.
Thank you guys for being
such a good group today.
I have really enjoyed having a
story time and drawing with you.
Thank you guys.
Thank you
>> Speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.